今天呢
我們現在講一檔股票
叫00403A
那00403A
各位看一下
00403A
今天是這個台股成交量最大
420萬
你看喔
買超第一名
國泰最難的
每次都這樣
星光也是散戶最大的分點
第二大的分點
叫星光
所以一看就知道
國泰都佔了好幾個嘛
國泰專門吸引散戶的
那這買價10.73
其實看起來他們很開心
目前看起來是賺錢的
所以呢
賺錢講話特別嗆
所以呢我今天講說00403A有溢價
一對人來嗆瞎你知道嗎
那00403A齁今天呢他是
市場溢價的
這個收盤價10.8
那禁止才10.23啊
你知道禁止10.23什麼意思啊
就是你假如可以在市場上認購
00403A的話
有一個東西呢
叫做初級市場
初級市場呢你可以去問你的營業員
我可以來認購00403A
初級市場認
所以套利方法就是第一個
龍券放空鎖單然後去市場上認
認了之後呢兩天到你的戶頭
兩天到你的戶頭之後呢
你就可以做一件事啊
你就可以來做一件事叫現券償還
這個是500張一組
500張一組就是500萬
500萬就可以套了
我已經跟營業員講好了說我們一定要認
那明天一定很多人去認
為什麼
因為
01403A明天可能就有
龍券了
各位看到沒有
龍券出來啦
今天融資十萬張
笑欸
明天一定一堆龍券
今天就一堆人已經先去空了
那01403A的下場呢
會跟誰一樣
我跟各位講
這議價很快就會收斂
只要可以套利就收斂
龍券空給他死當然收斂啊
你融券空了你又不怕被嘎空了兩天後你的任的股票就來了嘛你任的股票就來了然後呢就可以幹嘛做現券償還就好
你龍券連補都不用補
歷史不斷重演
老牛說得很好
小哥真好心提醒
你要跟台灣人說CP值很差
對
講CP值很差可以啦
你要買這個
你去買CP值好的嗎
你買這個幹嘛
假的5%對不對
買一台電視
你加100元就不賺了
然後買個ETF多人家5%
然後怎麼樣
然後很開心
很開心喔 你看喔
買台股假設買20萬一張的台股能買啥
你可以買台積電90股
台積電買個90股至少沒有溢價
你買台積電90股也可以買
難道403A他買這三個月都不會漲嗎
我講的是溢價 你跟我講他會不會漲
對不對
我講的溢價溢價5%什麼意思
你買就是買台股多少
你現在買就是買台股4萬點的位置
假設三個月後漲到5萬點
你403A當然也會漲
當然也會漲嘛
那假如三個月後漲到4萬3千點就好了
你403A是跌的
你懂嗎 你的403A會變跌的
但是你買指數都是漲的
所以我們用邏輯理論來講股票
那別人呢
用情感來回復我們
你知道嗎
我為什麼要講這些呢
我總不能以老賣了
看起來也怪怪的
對不對
那我們至少在市場上很久
我們都知道說
這個這市場上
什麼事該做什麼事不該做
所以這邊也寫得很好啊
祝這453張一路順遂
繼續尻寄沒多少錢
沒多少錢你可以去買別的
你可以去買他成份股
你買什麼403A
你知道嗎
美股地位ETF也是一開始猶豫
後來沒有藍後直接噴發
欸 又來了
又來了
然後就開始跟你寫別的
然後說直接噴發
就是鼓勵人家買嘛閃物沒在看禁止溢價的我只能說小哥信仰價值不過下個月漲到20塊關你什麼5%議價欸 你漲到20塊 什麼意思
漲到20塊台股是7萬點
至少
至少7萬點
欸 各位
你要不要去看他的成分股啊
他現在00403A的成分股
其實跟很多成...很多
00981A的成分股有的類似啊
他不是去買00981A15塊錢
那時候的股票
他也是去買00981A30塊的時候的股票
00981A現在30塊
403A現在是10塊
他們未來的價差
大概就是
這樣子
大概就是三倍
你假如是
這個981A跟403A的比值
他約莫不大會變動
不大會變動
但是我跟各位講00403A呢
他之後呢會有一個很大幅的跌回來
為什麼因為
因為他要先把這個溢價給收斂
所以呢 一堆人不懂
然後就來這邊嗆
你看
00981A 沒買到現在都長到30元了
過這次就15 20元還在那一價
還在那一價
你最好15 20
就一直上去
你明天只要可以申購
你就看到盤中一堆龍券在那邊空
空了也不用回補 反正只要怎麼樣
你只要申購完兩天後還券
事情就解決了
前陣子長太兄現在一堆人不把這5帕看上去
只是我們都講這個
溢價多了就是不能買
再講一次溢價多了就不能買
因為他存在了套利空間
你看這個又嗆了
溢價為何不先假設
如果大盤繼續上漲
請問有溢價問題嗎
大盤繼續上漲你不會買台子旗喔
不會買0050
你一定要為什麼一定要買這種溢價5%的
大盤有可能漲了5%之後
他先修正這個溢價
你懂嗎
他先修正这一架然后后面的后面涨去
那你看一下今天今天有人贴啦今天外资卖的外资为什么卖因为他可以套啊 但賣啊自營商避險自營商這個就是造勢啊 今天賣了243萬張給散戶
成分股也差太多了 正在分析不認同
我在說預價 你還要說成分股
98AA都幾次預價了
起碼還把台股撐上一片天
你呢?
有夠強
超級強
我交易稅交很多也把台股撐上一片天
你呢?
換我槍回去 我教會所以也嚼很多啊
喔 這一圈 這很爽啊
這個現賣 預價5% 現股賣出
很爽啊 對不對
反正呢 只要怎麼樣 只要可以申購
它那個預價就是會收斂
好 我們來看一下 00403A成分股
那買這些 大部分 981A都有啊
你買981A就好啊 你買403A 對不對
伯伯都差不多的東西
有人預價5%你要買
有人預價沒那麼多
你現在981A預價多少
反正不會到5%啦 不可能5%
今天預價0.23%
0.23%合宜
有人嗆我說什麼
981A都預價很多沒有
我現在看很少有一天預價超過1%的
很少我現在看最近這兩個月是沒有
成本股都一樣
成本無論一樣 你就要買403 加人5%
人家買的是未稅 你買的都要含稅
然後你要賣的時候 怎麼稅不見了 怎麼5%不見了
然後到時候再嗆說 投信坑殺你 投信也沒有坑殺你
今天投信都已經發文了 說 議價不要再買了
那我今天也發文了 跟你講說 議價你還可以來套利
你可以套利喔 那我們秉持著良心路線
總是要告訴你 我明天我要申購好不好
明天有申購
我就申購
有申購我一定空爆他
我申購1000張我就空1000張
好不好
403A就這樣
403A各位
403A不要
去追了
好不好
預價太多